welcome to this video playing shovel
from from Spain so Williams oh I guess
yep okay check my the positions that i
get from the zimage are really that good
really no degree is not to play it
sometimes which i would score more
points but this is very often due to my
awful time management ok so is some
going for this this blocked center it's
not a strategy I like very much as long
as white is not as long as in a
situation where why it is not castle yet
really don't think that this is some
very good can go here yeah those pieces
I don't know
so g4s reh for what we should be three
units to Bishop e3 first
the end I will going to play g-form
figures f5 now maybe you can make a peak
speed sacrifice out of it could this
could be interesting if I've take a
couple of times G form then some sort of
peace sacrifice rook f3 takes Queen edge
for check maybe maybe
if he's not playing a five I will play G
for next ok maybe I must I must be
cautious on g4 he might have he might
have night age form
g49 h4 but then i can go king of two
right so let's do that night f40 is a
pawn sec it sometimes possible like in
the Kings Indian it's very often
possible to sacrifice a pawn like that
but he I don't really think there's any
compensation Queen h4 check this Bishop
f2 so at the end he retreats um how to
to do this now
yeah maybe you start with this that's
okay i'm the best setup Bishop g5 is
also a move okay not not anymore pin but
night f5 isn't this season's is already
a bit a bit problematic d 6 is hanging
and if you take on the G file I mean
okay so i can take them
hmm
okay i'm going to take and they can I
can take him next smooth also let's
maybe to eat too actually i don't know i
don't want to spend too much time
if it tries to keep this with night h5 I
go rook g5 which pretty much show shows
that this is not a move tool to be
played
that's a very slow move running ok I can
go here takes
after the capture I don't want my bishop
attacked so that I can directly and fly
Quincy five or queen txt six just a
prophylactic move
also 9075 might come with the tempo I
can still take a forum next here Queen
takes 26 maybe I could also just double
on the G huh this is not bad
I but okay come on let's just ditch the
stake him I take d 6 yeah he's got 24
check this is not very very very nice
I don't know and I spend too much time
yay again
I've seen a h2 but I don't think it's
it's so great gives me to open files
against the king rook g2 with a new
gauge one check check now he's got the
checker forgot about that that's it's
that set stupid really and this was more
stupid Eden what am I doing here hello
hello from this position unbelievable ok
check gather the funny thing is the
position is still interesting because of
my big Center so not not great or
anything but time was not an easy win
for black I don't think so
check mmm nice is relatively quick them
hmm f u5 check though I don't have you
five check ah I'm this is a pin
life perhaps i'm really i'm only mr.
find how can I not win the position look
at this this is a completely over you
yeah but I didn't play it clear didn't
play it down player precisely I can take
d6 maybe I should just do that yeah why
not actually 24 check i go to g2 yeah
yeah but the main thing of course was i
forgot that he has such a that he has
queen age 5 something like that it's
still still okay for me even if the
computer is not agreeing i don't i don't
mind that i can i can easily play the
position very very of stupid play yeah i
think this was this was okay yeah well
the computer gives rook see one is even
better this was my first idea but it
felt felt felt weird somehow but it is
ok i mean i just pick up f4 and have to
sell this pawn mess in the center and
the GE file so I just must avoid to to
blunder all my pieces which I did yeah
ok thanks for watching